welcome back and I will now do that same
problem in a much easier way so the
problem with me let me clear it a little
bit so the original problem we said you
know we apply some force to M sub 0 and
that gives some acceleration a sub 0 and
then we said when we apply the same
force to a combination of M sub 0 and M
sub 1 we get 150 acceleration 1/5 a sub
0 and we worked it through with all the
variables well I'll show you is you
could actually do this type of problem
just by substituting numbers and and
this is this is kind of quick and dirty
but it's good to do a reality check and
often times you can you can solve the
problem without having to go through all
the variable mess so I could just pick
some numbers here so I could say well
what if F sub 0 is equal to 10 Newton's
M sub 0 is equal to I don't know to
kilograms and then a sub 0 is equal to
well it would be 10 divided by 2 right
because force is equal to mass times
acceleration so it'd be 5 meters per
second squared all right and then in
this case we still have this this would
be 10 Newton's this would be 10 Newton's
one-fifth a sub 0 well there'll be one
fifth this would be 1 meters per second
squared and then we could solve for what
the new mass is well how would we do
that well we have force which is 10
Newton's is equal to the sum of the
masses so M 1 plus M sub 0 but M sub 0
we already learned is two kilograms
times the acceleration times one fifth a
sub zero which is 1 meter per second
squared so then we have this one you
know we could ignore it essentially so
then we essentially have that 10 and
since all of our units are right we can
kind of drop the unit's because we know
they work out 10 is equal to m1 plus 2
so you get m1 is equal to 8 and then
once again if we want to know the ratio
of M sub 0 to M
one we can just substitute the numbers M
sub zero is two kilograms M sub one is
eight kilograms so the ratio is one to
four you probably find that a little bit
easier let's do another problem
another problem
oops okay this next problem I think
you'll find interesting so let's say I
have a skydiver and he's you know he's
in this guy diver position you know
falling towards the ground and let's say
he weighs 70 kilograms so his mass is
equal to 70 kilograms let's say that the
terminal velocity is a hundred and
twenty miles per hour so he's moving
downward with at 120 miles per hour
which is actually accurate I've gone
skydiving 120 miles per hour and if we
convert that you could convert that for
fun into the metric system but but I'll
do that for you but it's good to know
you just so you have a sense of how fast
you fall when you skydive before the
parachute opens this translates to about
fifty three point six meters per second
I'm reading this from a problem from a
website at the University of Oregon
anyway they are asking us what force
does air resistance exert on the
skydiver so let's be clear a couple of
things this 120 miles per hour this is
the skydivers terminal velocity and if
you're not familiar with what terminal
velocity is I will now explain it to you
so when you fall from a plane you have a
bunch of wind pushing on you right you
have a lot of wind resistance the wind
is it causes friction it slows you down
as you can imagine that's how a
parachute works it just creates the the
it allows the wind it creates a lot more
resistance from the wind and then you
slow down so the terminal velocity the
terminal velocity is the velocity at
which you you no longer go faster then
so it's it's the velocity at which you
stop accelerating or yeah it's the
velocity you reach and you don't go any
faster than that and it's basically
based on on you know your wind
resistance
the terminal-velocity your acceleration
is zero acceleration is zero so what we
know is is that the force of the air we
could call that the air force so we know
that the force of the air is exactly
equal to the force of gravity the force
of gravity and how do we know that
because the guy is not accelerating he
it's his terminal velocity he's he's at
a very high speed he had accelerated all
the way to this point but the more he
accelerated the faster he got the the
more resistance the wind provided up to
a point where the wind provided so much
resistance that he stopped going any
faster and that's the terminal velocity
so at terminal velocity the force of the
air is equal to the force of gravity and
what's the force of gravity well the
force of gravity is just the guys weight
so the force of gravity is equal to the
guy's mass 70 kilograms and we have our
unit's right 70 kilograms times
acceleration of gravity well the
acceleration of gravity is 9.8 roughly
meters per second squared we could use a
calculator to calculate this 70 I could
I feel cheap now I could have done it by
hand anyway 686 so it equals 686 Newtons
now the second part of the question and
this is interesting
if the skydiver pulls in their arm and
aims their body downward so now the
skydivers looks more like this and he
pulled in his arms and he aimed his body
down right so he's he's diving really
the terminal velocity can be increased
to about 180 miles per hour or 80.5
meters per second they give us this we
could have figured it out though so now
he's going a lot faster almost that but
roughly 50% faster than he was or maybe
well 30% faster than he was going before
he's going a lot faster and why is that
because he's more aerodynamic now he's
the you know and well we'll do more more
on pressure later but I want you to get
the intuition that you know
when you're laying flat there's there's
just a lot of wind pressing against your
body you have a lot of surface area
exposed to the wind but when you're
diving in this situation like the
skydiver is he has a lot less exposed to
the wind really just his head his head
is breaking the wind and nothing else
and that's why he's it takes a lot more
speed for the for them for the force of
the wind resistance to match the force
of gravity so the question is asking if
the skydiver pulls in their arms and
aims their body downward the terminal
velocity can be increased to about 80
point five meters per second or 180
miles per hour so it's going very fast
what force does air resistance now exert
on the skydiver and I'll let you think
about that for a second maybe you want
to pause it and think of it for yourself
and and now that you've unpause it I'll
tell you that this is a trick question
because once again the skydiver has
reached a new terminal velocity by
definition at the terminal velocity the
skydiver is no longer accelerating the
skydiver is not going any faster because
the wind resistance is so strong that it
completely matches the force of gravity
so once again the wind resistance the
force of the air or the force of the
wind is equal to the force of gravity
and what is the force of gravity well
that's his weight and we already figured
that out that was 686 Newtons and I know
what you're thinking you're saying Sal
this doesn't make sense
he's now going so much faster doesn't
doesn't the air exert more force on him
well no he's he's the air is exerting
the same force if he was going if he was
going that same speed but he was
flattened out I would agree with you the
the air would be exerting more force on
him but what's happened now is that he
he's once again reached a state where
his acceleration is zero it's at a
higher velocity and you want to I want
you to think a lot about this he's at a
much higher velocity now so there's so
in on his head for example to just
there's a lot more wind going by but
it's it's pressing on a smaller surface
area right and I'm not going to go too
much in the detail of pressure right now
but I want to get that intuition
so although the wind is going a lot
faster it's going a lot faster on a
smaller area and it's actual force is
the exact same thing and we know that
because he's not accelerating anymore
because he's at his terminal velocity so
think about that a bit it's a bit of a
trick question but I think it gives you
a good intuition on what acceleration
means what terminal velocity means and
and they'll start to give you a little
bit of an intuition on on uneven wind
resistance on pressure I'll see you in
the next video